la Russie annonce qu'elle envoie des
avions équipés de missiles hypersonique
dernier cri dans son enclave de
Kaliningrad voilà absolument la Russie
annonce que à la déployé 3 mig euh 31
donc avec des missiles hypersoniques
king-jall qui ont été déployés sur le
principal aérodrome de la région de
Kaliningrad alors pour les
téléspectateurs qui ne suivent pas tous
les détours tours et des tours de
l'histoire européenne on doit appeler
ningrad on le voit sur la cadre là c'est
une c'est une enclave qui appartient à
la Russie mais qui est situé entre la
Pologne et les États baltes la Lituanie
notamment et en Europe centrale en
Europe centrale absolument on le voit et
donc c'est l'objet effectivement d'un
véritable bras de fer entre l'Union
européenne et Moscou surtout depuis le
déclenchement de la guerre en
Ukraine et récemment la Lituanie en
application des sanctions qui avaient
été décidées par l'Union européenne
contre Moscou avait décidé d'empêcher le
transit euh de l'essentiel des
marchandises qui transitaient donc
directement du territoire de la Russie
vers Kaliningrad vous voyez qui est
obligatoirement passer par la Lituanie
il y a eu de fortes protestations de la
Russie des menaces finalement les
Européens ont transigé en expliquant la
Lituanie qu'il fallait quand même
laisser passer un certain nombre de
marchandises à l'exception bien sûr de
tout ce qui pouvait être du matériel
militaire mais on voit que Moscou
entretient aussi l'attention dans cette
zone ce territoire qui est qui est petit
mais qui est déjà lourdement militarisé
alors le fait d'un certain avion avec
ses missiles hypersoniques dont Vladimir
Poutine dit que ce sont les meilleurs
armes du monde tout simplement parce
qu'elles peuvent échapper au système de
radar évidemment c'est une source
d'inquiétude au cœur même de l'Europe